[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laïcité le débat empoisonné bonjour à
tous peut-on débattre sereinement à
propos du voile des signes religieux
quel qu'il soit crystallis ton les
passions avec ces remises en cause
régulière de la laïcité à la française
issue de la loi de 1905
on va en débattre ce matin dans dimanche
en politique sur france 3 franche comté
avec nos trois invités
jérôme durain sénateur socialiste de
saône-et-loire président du groupe
majoritaire au conseil régional
également sur ce plateau jacques ricart
d'éthique conseiller régional au 6 mai
est membre vous du rassemblement
national de marine le pen maire de
tresses ans dans petite commune du doubs
et puis alain chrétien mais rossi mais
vous de vesoul en haute-saône
vous êtes membre fondateur d'agir la
droite constructive qui soutient
l'action du gouvernement et des manuels
mâcon bonjour à tous les trois merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
vous le savez c'est notre habitude vous
pouvez aussi vous aussi participer à ce
débat
commentez l'émission avec le mot diez
qui s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
alors messieurs notre région a été le
théâtre en l'espace de quelques semaines
de deux affaires très largement reprise
dans les médias il y a dix jours le
refus par un foyer logement de vezon de
l'accueillir une religieuse à la
retraite si elle ne quittait pas son
habit de clarisse et puis le 11 octobre
dernier il ya quelques semaines donc au
conseil régional à dijon en pleine
session juin au 12 le patron du groupe
rassemblement national demande la parole
voici ce qu'il dit mme la présidente
je vais vous demander s'il vous plaît au
nom de nos principes laïques de bien
vouloir demander de bien vouloir
demander à l'accompagnatrice qui vient
de rentrer dans cette salle de bien de
bien vouloir retirer son voile islamique
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
alors après quelques minutes
d'atermoiements la présidente
marie-guite dufay reprend la parole
refuse la demande de julien odoul mais
la polémique est lancée et pendant
plusieurs semaines le débat sur le voile
tournent en boucle sur les plateaux de
télévision
jérôme durain vous étiez à cette session
du conseil régional
est-ce que l'écho qu'a eue la sortie de
julien jousse vous a surpris agacé
surtout plus que surpris parce que on
est là pour parler de laïcité j'hésite à
venir en disant on va pas encore parler
de laïcité parce que je crois qu'au fond
dans la population
le souci d'aller visiter il est bien
moins important que sur les plateaux de
télé une espèce d'hystérie za sion
politique de ce sujet qui correspond pas
aux attendes associés vous allez pas
encore nous dire la faute aux médias
l'enjeu dépasse à jeu du je dis qu'il ya
un certain nombre de composantes de
notre vie politique qui font leur
business avec la laïcité
la preuve cet incident il suffisait de
dire si j'avais été julien au 12e ce que
je ne suis pas madame la présidente on
peut avoir une suspension de séance et
on aurait réglé ça tranquillement
là il fait le buzz il choisit d'ailleurs
le ces termes est ce qu'elle peut
enlever son voile islamique
donc il fait de la politique il enfonce
oncle ou alors que ça n'a rien à voir
que la laïcité c'est juste une forme de
provocation pour alimenter un business
politique jacques ricart d'éthique août
comme de votre président de groupe au
conseil régional
bien évidemment que tu arrêtes lorca
monsieur du rhin que c'est un sujet qui
intéresse les gens m'aiment
effectivement s'il n'est pas là pour
attester risée je rappelle que 70 %
suivent notre notre façon de penser
c'est à dire que les accompagnatrices
scolaires devraient pas être voilées en
france
ça ça me paraît le minimum de la laïcité
ben c'est pas la loi mais c'est la
laïcité que tout le monde réclame et que
la majorité des français veulent
réclamer
alors voilà monsieur du rein je suis
encore une fois je vous le redis 70%
c'est pas une paille
votre position vous avez vous avez vous
choisi de soutenir l'islamisme le plus
radical ici nombre jeune homme est bon
on va relancer le débat c'est vrai que c
est ce qu on combat l'islamisme en
refusant le voile aux accompagnatrice
scolaire à écouter car moi expliquer ce
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire le lien non
mais écoutez moi je fais ce que je vais
vous dire je vais reprendre les paroles
du président de la république qui a dit
que cette personne portait un voile et
que c'était un islam politique qu'elle
revendiquait
cette personne-là appartient au ccf le
ccf est largement dès qu'elle est
défendue rendu par le tf c'est un voile
c'est une revendication politique cette
cette dame à vendre avant de marquer une
soumission religieuse fait en plus de sa
une une démarche politique c'est à nice
l'homme politique qui revendique voilà
le septième en 1
vous n'êtes vous pas élu au conseil
régional comment vous avez vécu cette
séquence de l'extérieur je crois qu'il
faut prendre beaucoup de recul et que ce
sujet est un sujet qui intéresse les
français c'est vrai et que sur ce sujet
là il n'y a pas de consensus
on y reviendra tout à l'heure sur le
sujet de vesoul mais la difficulté de
cette laïcité c'est que tout le monde y
met un sens différent et que quand
chacun a sa propre définition des choses
et b n'y a pas de consensus et donc yade
à polémique en permanence et je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit la bonne manière que
de régler ce problème que de polémiquer
et de l'utiliser à des fins
politiciennes
l'essentiel c'est qu'un jour ou l'autre
la france se met d'accord avec cette
définition la laïcité est posé la
question aux français dans la rue par
anne ne vous donnera la même définition
de ce mot si important aujourd'hui dans
notre société alors l'ampleur il ya eu
le 11 octobre avec la session du conseil
régional il ya eu aussi quelques
semaines plus tard la faire de vesoul
qui a une ampleur médiatique aussi assez
extraordinaire puisque ça a été repris
par des médias étrangers
est ce que cette ampleur médiatique elle
vous a pris de court alors c'était pas
il ya dix jours sept soeurs clarisses
c'était mois de juillet qu'elle a trouvé
un logement ailleurs qu'au foyer
logement c'est au mois de juillet et
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous rassurer est
là où elle est aujourd'hui elle se sent
très bien et je pense que elle est la
première à être désolé de cette
polémique qui a jailli sur elle parce
qu'à mon avis elle n'en voulait pas
premier point le deuxième point c'est
qu'effectivement il ya eu une faute de
la part des services
je les dis la loi elle éclaire sur ce
sujet là le principe de laïcité
neutralité s'appliquent aux agents du
service public et pas aux résidents les
choses sont claires je les ai rappelés
ces principes aux services municipaux il
ya aucune ambiguïté j'ai bloqué une
faute on est bien d'accord que les
services municipaux qui ont administré
qui ont qu'ils ont
viser cette demande d'intégration au
foyer logement d'accueil
ils se sont trompés ils ne respectaient
pas la loi tout à fait c'est ce que je
leur ai dit et je les rappeler très
rapidement lorsque cette polémique est
revenue sur le tapis trois mois après
parce que c'était une affaire qui datait
de cet été mais pourquoi cette faute
parce que je crois que les services ont
cherché un compromis parce que quand
vous avez accueilli une religieuse dans
un établissement
eh bien il ya des gens c'est bien on
sait pas bien je ne sais pas mais qu'ils
disent je n'ai pas envie de prendre mon
petit déjeuner avec une religieuse en
habit religieux
ça existe et quand vous êtes confrontés
à ça que vous devez faire vivre 170
résidant dans un foyer logement
vous essayez de trouver des compromis
des compromis pour que chacun puisse
trouver sa place
ce compromis il n'a pas été acceptée par
la soeur et je la comprends
et en plus ce compromis il n'est pas
légal parce que justement la loi il est
clair qu'une religieuse peut très bien
venir en habit religieux alors dans un
établissement public
alors vous le dit la loi est claire mais
en fait le point commun ces deux
affaires c'est quand même la
méconnaissance notamment par les
services parce qu'il ya eu aussi au
conseil régional
un temps de latence ou notamment la
présidente ne savait pas trop sur quel
pied danser suite à la demande de julien
odoul pourtant la loi est claire c'est
ce qu'a rappelé le président de la
république quelques jours après je vous
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron
c'était le 25 octobre le port du voile
dans l'espace public n'est pas mon
affaire
c'est ça la laïcité le port du voile
dans les services publics à l'école
quand on éduque nos enfants c'est mon
affaire
c'est ça la laïcité ça veut dire que
quand on est dans un espace où le
service public est rendu il y a un
devoir de neutralité des agents
[Musique]
le port du voile dans l'espace public ce
n'est pas mon affaire dit emmanuel
macron jérôme durain il s'en lave les
mains président de la république ou au
contraire il est pile dans la ligne de
la laïcité à la française
moi j'aurais préféré qu'il soit plus
plus affirmatif est plus positif on a
l'impression dans la période que la
laïcité c'est ce par quoi on s'en prend
à une maman devant son fils et ce par
quoi on embête une vieille dame qui n'a
rien demandé par les jeunes de vesoul
laïcité ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'agressif c'est un outil de protection
c'est un outil qui permet la concorde
républicaine qui permet de vivre
ensemble et aujourd'hui au conseil
régional par exemple ce qu'on a c'est
une assise de laïcité dévoyé c'est une
arme de guerre est à dire qu on essaye
de dévoyer la laïcité pour en faire
quelque chose contre une religion en
particulier il n'y a pas de sujet au
fond avec la religion catholique avec le
christianisme en général c'est surtout
une posture et monsieur rijkaard et il a
dit tout à l'heure
anti islamiques et les mots viennent
très vite alors monsieur odoul la région
ils ne parlent que de ça et toutes les
politiques régionales sont vu par le
prisme l'islam ce qui n'a rien à voir
avec la laïcité
la laïcité c'est la neutralité toutes
les politiques régionales de toutes les
initiatives du rassemblement elle
voulait dire vous parler de la politique
régionale de la vie politique régionale
dans l'oeil du rassemble un ami
nationale s'est vu par le prisme de
l'islam des migrants de la préférence
étrangère ce que d'aucuns valu un
dévoiement absolu de la lei spécialité
ces faits pour vivre ensemble c'est
l'universel et c'est pas l'identitaire
celle inverse de ce que pense le
rassemblement va du tout pas du tout
monsieur durand leur nombre alors l'on
fait surtout pas l'amalgamé entre
l'islam et l'islamisme pour nous il ya
une grande différence
il ya une grande différence on a des
cons patriotisme musulmans qui
appartiennent et qui sont au
rassemblement national que nous
respectons nous nous avons la vraie
laïcité ce que nous combattons c'est
l'islamisme
voilà d'islamisme ça un mot le islamisme
ses 800 morts je n'aurais pas non plus
mais je rappelle tout de même et je veux
revenir sur cette histoire de voile
parce que
en faut appeler un chat un chat et je
reviens et je redis encore une fois que
c'est pas anodin cette personne au sein
d'un hémicycle républicain au sein
d'année d'un hémicycle élu
démocratiquement avec un voile qui n'est
pas seulement un voile simple je dirais
milk est aussi un voile qui représente
un combat un combat politique
nous avions en face de nous une
militante politique qui a été
instrumentalisée sim gt1 dans son studio
à l'effet que nous vous en user pas du
tout elle appartient elle à part les
avait laissés veille qu'elle allait
venir sur le plateau du conseil régional
au dessus du rhin si monsieur du rhin
les jacqueries cardetti c'est
effectivement ce qu'ont dit les
institutrices qui accompagnait le groupe
la maman n'était pas prévu la maman qui
a été pointée du doigt et et enfin c'est
cette sortie bon on a quelques antennes
tout de même été organisé par des
conseillers régionaux un des
départements du nord franche comté du 90
cette sortie était prévue et ce jour là
était prévu voilà cette personne là
n'est pas arrivée là par hasard
elles représentent elles représentent un
islam politique d'où le désarroi de
madame d'où le désarroi de main de
madame la présidente qui qui est qui qui
savait que ce jour-là y allait avoir
cette visite scolaire c'est quand elle a
vu la personne qui sait trouver d'où son
désappointement ainsi que celui de son
dgs
alors moi je vais bien général les
services soient exactement je voudrais
je veux bien quand je veux bien qu'on
raconte ce qu'on veut ou qu'on rend
compte après coup mais bon on l'a vu
tout se réformer la laïcité ça veut dire
quoi jacques ricart les diront le
rassemblement national n'y a pas de
réforme y a pas de réforme de la laïcité
il ya simplement une loi de 1905 qui qui
a fait qu'ils autorisent aujourd'hui les
accompagnatrices scolaire a planté le
voile si elle bat le mans exactement b
donc la volonté la volonté du
législateur si un jour nous arrivons
nous arrivons ne me regarde pas écouté
dieu vous en garde peut-être voilà mais
encore une fois ce sera la voix des
électeurs et des électrices nous nous
voudrons réforme nous voulons réformer
ceci parce que quelle est l'épaisseur
la différence est la feuille de
cigarette entre la personne qui
accompagne qui accompagnent les enfants
et l'institutrice où le personnel qui
est de la manger dans une dans une
cantine scolaire c'est la même chose
c'est la même chose moi je pense aux
personnes qui sont pas musulmanes et qui
voit à côté d'une maman avec un voile
qui représente un islam politique alors
chacun
sa vision de la laïcité française vous
l'avez dit les uns et les autres est
qu'il y à la loi est la loi
certains sénateurs notamment des
sénateurs les républicains ont tenté de
la faire évoluer en passant un texte au
sénat il y a quelques semaines pour
justement interdire le port de signes
religieux pour les accompagnatrices
scolaire alain chrétien
vous êtes vous étiez membre du parti des
républicains
quelle est votre position par rapport à
cette question est ce que vos anciens
camarades républicains au sénat ils ont
raison ou est-ce que vous êtes sur la
ligne
présidentielle on va dire on touche à
rien pour l'instant je crois que ça
c'est rien de toucher à sousse à tout ça
parce que justement on est encore pas de
l'accord sur la loi existante et vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez tous dit il ya un
vrai débat vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
la loi existe si je suis allé à votre
position sur les accompagnatrices je
suis l accord avec la loi existante sauf
qu'il ya des jurisprudences qui sont
différentes
la jurisprudence le contentieux les
juges ont pas encore stabilisé les
choses est ce qu'une accompagnatrice
scolaire est un agent du service public
ou pas aujourd'hui non et voilà donc
elle a le droit de porter le voile c'est
aussi simple que ça ça vous convient d
ça me convient parce que c'est la loi
elle elle me comptez vous pouvez avoir
le droit de vous aussi de vouloir
changer la loi non parce que je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un débat qui
concerne tout le monde et qui serait
nécessaire d'appliquer la loi existante
or que vous l'avez vu les services sont
tétanisés je crois même qu autour de la
présidente on savait pas trop quoi faire
et ce qu'elle avait le droit ou pas le
droit
chez moi les services étaient aussi
tétanisés parce que ce sujet est
tellement inflammable que dès qu'on
prend une décision quelle qu'elle soit
on fait des mécontents
comment voulez-vous réformer une loi
dans un contexte est aussi hystérique
alors qu'il faudrait de la sérénité du
recul et de la distance pour trouver la
bonne direction parce que tout ça ça
fait quoi
eh bien ça renforce sa renforce les gens
et les gens les uns contre les autres et
réformer une loi dans ce contexte là
forcément vous trouverez pas la bonne
soldats alors justement les musulmans
vous parlez de monter les gens les uns
contre les autres les musulmans
clairement se sentent visés par les
polémiques des dernières semaines il ya
eu des manifestations contre ce que l'on
appelle l'islamophobie à paris mais
aussi à belfort dans notre région
c'était le 2 novembre
et voici ce que l'on pouvait entendre
parmi les manifestantes et les
manifestants on sent toujours harceler
les musulmans à chaque fois il ya un
événement c'est les musulmans qui
prennent tous nous sommes citoyens
français nous avons droit de porter le
voile sans se faire quand tu dois veut
nous faire croire que on est similaire
aux terroristes alors que pas du tout je
pense que si on se renseigne un petit
peu plus on comprendra que c'est une
religion de paix d'acceptation donc de
tolérance ils ont tous les droits ils
ont les devoirs ils ont il faut que
cette communauté soit considéré comme
étant des citoyens à part entière pas
entièrement à part jacques ricart des ti
est ce que les musulmans ont raison de
se sentir comme des citoyens entièrement
à part c'est pas du tout des citoyens
apport moi je je rappelle je rappelle
l'histoire en 1905 sa pas été facile de
mettre à genoux la catholicité et la
chrétienté
voilà je pense que ces gens là il ya une
part d'assimilation ça se travaille
il faut aussi que ces gens-là fasse
amende honorable je rappelle encore une
fois que que ce qui tue chez nous c'est
le terrorisme islamiste
ce n'est pas la confusion entre islam et
islamisme pas du tout mais pas du tout
c'est m
mais mais pas du tout mais qu'ils en
voulaient que le lien à chaque noël bien
sûr je fais le lien parce que c'est
celui là qui doit être fait je suis
désolé monsieur monsieur chevreuils mais
je je je je peine à le dire je le redis
encore une fois ce terroriste 7 un
terroriste islamiste
trouvez moi un autre mot jeanjean paraît
un autre mot qu'islamistes c'est un
terrorisme vous avez un autre mot
qu'islamistes mais ce que pour lutter
contre le terrorisme lors d'un
mentaliste islamistes est ce que pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et contre
l'islamisme la priorité c'est
d'interdire le voile des
accompagnatrices ce que l'on voit quand
on voit que les prêches radicaux
je veux bien mais quand on parle
d'épanouissement de la femme de demi
tout et compagnie d'égalité homme femme
bon ce voile porté comme une soumission
à l'homme et aux préceptes religieux je
veux dire on est bien loin de la
république tout de même jérôme durain
lors de la session régionale suivante
vous avez dans une longue tirade fustigé
la position
du rassemblement national notamment sa
position sur la laïcité avec une laïcité
à deux vitesses jamais un parti
politique n'aura aussi mal porté son
entrée sur dont rassemblement national
alors que son objectif c'est de diviser
monsieur rijkaard et y c'est pas
compliqué vous lui posez la question du
voile dans la seconde il vous parle
d'islamisme de terrorisme et de mort
donc là des amalgames absolue
effectivement c'est une laïcité à deux
vitesses parce que excusez moi à bayonne
l'attentât celui qui a failli coûter la
vie à des personnes s'étaient pas des
islamistes donc et les 350 personnes qui
sont crainte par les services de
renseignement parce que elle appartenait
lui fera droite et qu'elles ont des
armes et les 147 qui sont fichés sc pas
des islamistes donc arrêtons de ramener
toute une communauté nationale à cette
seule question est toute une partie de
cette communauté musulmane à l'islamisme
parce que la dame dont vous parlez qui a
dévoilé ce jour là je ne la connais pas
je ne veux pas savoir quels sont ses
opinions mais elle était pas là pour
faire l'apologie qu'islam politique
quand monsieur odoul nous dit les
services de la région
en gros sont gangrénés par l'islam
politique c'est quand même qu'un petit
un petit sujet pas le l'aller les fils
se touchent je veux répondre là dessus
oui mais devrait voir plus bas monsieur
la réalité quand même c'est que dans la
laïcité telle qu'elle est prônée par
l'assemblée nationale
on a une forme d'agression contre les
valeurs républicaines la laïcité c'est
fait pour vivre ensemble personne n'est
pour le communautarisme
personne n'est pour l'islamisme mais
c'est pas la peine de désigner et de
mettre à l'index toute une partie de la
population mais surtout parce que ça
vous fait prospérer dans les ira du tout
pas du tout pas du tout je vous rappelle
qu'on a des militants chez nous qui sont
dès qu'ils sont musulmans et qui qui qui
suivent nos idées qu'ils défendent
d'être notre laïcité alors joint revenir
sur cette histoire de des services des
services en bourgogne franche comté
parce que là aussi faut être clair je
vais vous donner l'exemple concret de
de ces problèmes et des ce problème de
communautarisme au sein des services
très simplement voilà je vous donne mais
je vous dis ce qu'il en est un
micro-ondes dans un service du conseil
régional une personne fait cuire
saucisses lentilles avec du pauvre une
personne de ses services repassant
derrière refuse en refusant et
invectivant sa collègue pour avoir fait
cuire au sein de ce micro ondes des
lentilles avec du porc c'est là vers du
siècle oui mais c'est la sphère du sein
de miss pau et on va changer la loi sur
les bonus non mais ça c'est de se sentir
c'est une c'est une intolérance monsieur
oui c'est une intolérance et la laïcité
doit s'appliquer aussi au sein des
services et je le redis je leur ai dit
la personne qui est venue en
accompagnement scolaire et ça bien et ça
a bien surpris madame la présidente et
son dg l'église au courant oui non mais
elle était au courant qu'il y avait une
visite scolaire mais ne savait pas qui
allait se dérouler comme ça elle était
la première en bété et je pense que
c'est au sein de votre majorité vous
avez des gens qui vous tendent des
pièges pour cette laïcité et vous pensez
bien vous pensez bien que là on est là
pour le pour le dire
pour le dire parce que nos électeurs
nous le demande je rappelle que 70 %
monsieur du rhin sont contre ses
accompagnatrices voilée dans les écoles
je rappelle aussi que ont fait 26 % au
sein de la bourgogne franche comté
tandis que votre parti le parti
socialiste fait 6%
donc vous pouvez toujours chassé du côté
du communautarisme ou aller chercher ces
gens là pour vous soutenir ça suffira
pas écoutez moi je suis catholique que
j'ai été baptisé donc je peux pas on
peut difficilement me taxer d'être
intéressés par l'islam politique
vous avez juste un petit problème avec
une partie de notre société une partie
de ses représentants une religion en
particulier vous dévoyez la cité et puis
aux affaires de saucisses lentilles
s'intéressent pas grand monde au fonds
alors sur la distinction que font
certains entre les religions c'est aussi
semble-t-il la position du père florent
belin c'est le prêtre de vesoul qui en
fait révélé l'histoire de la religieuse
avec son édito dans le bulletin
paroissial et le père belin prenant
référence sur la sphère
dijon et du conseil régional dit qu'il
ne pense pas que le voile d'une
religieuse puisse nuire car elle n'est
pas le signe d'une soumission mais d'une
consécration le voile catholique c'est
bien le voile islamique c'est pas bien
on en est là vous savez quelle que soit
la religion quand le signe religieux
devient un signe politique on rentre
dans une dérive donc le voile des
musulmanes c'est forcément un signe
positif a déclaré tiens je n'ai pas des
meilleures tout dépend du sens renvoi
des distinctions en fait ça dépend du
sens qu'on veut donner
et quand un signe religieux devient un
outil politique on entre dans une dérive
kid est inacceptable parce que tous ces
signes plusieurs sens
un signe cultuelle hassine culturel ou
un signe politique
effectivement certains utilisent ces
signes religieux catholiques musulmans
israélite comme outil politique en
israël par exemple où la liste il existe
plein n'existe pas la religion fait
partie du de la société et ça ne dérange
personne
chez nous ça nous dérange on a une
histoire différents pays occidentaux où
on peut voir aussi des élus avec des
signes religieux ça pose aucun souci
s'il ya un débat et je trouve qu'en ce
moment notre société évolue sur ce sujet
il faut simplement qu'on le prenne avec
sérénité à distance on n'est pas là pour
gagner les élections sur ce sujet là on
est là pour trouver une solution qui
nous grandissent tous et que nos
compatriotes musulmans se sont aussi
bien en france que les français qui sont
catholiques
moi je ne suis plus dans cette
distinction là la seule limite c'est
quand on utilise à un signe religieux
comme outil de propagande politique
effectivement la grande difficulté c'est
de savoir quand ce signe religieux est
utilisé comme outil politique
est-ce que c'était le chaos concernant
le franche comté j'en sais rien est-ce
que c'était le cas de la religieuse de
vesoul sûrement pas elle n'est pas venue
au foyer logement pour faire du
prosélytisme
elle était tout à fait dans son droit
alors je vous ai dit qu'on allait faire
réagir les internautes et on va pas se
cacher derrière notre petit doigt on a
beaucoup de commentaires notamment sur
le modèle de fabien qui nous dit en
france on vit comme les français s'ils
veulent vivre comme dans leur pays
qu'ils y retournent
jérôme durain que répondre à ces
citoyens qui visiblement ne supporte pas
la vue
d'un voile que nous sommes dans une
société qui a changé et qu aujourd'hui
avec la mondialisation des transferts de
population on apprend à vivre avec
d'autres cultures
à une époque même dans les pratiques
alimentaires mais s'intéressent beaucoup
monsieur rijkaard et si on mangeait pas
la même chose qu'aujourd'hui on s'est
ouvert à d'autres cultures
on a décodé populations qui viennent
d'autres pays et qu'effectivement dans
notre dans notre pays avec la laïcité
c'est la loi plutôt que la fois et
parfois certaines populations certaines
communautés continuent à voir pour la
première génération des pratiques dont
je pense personnellement qu'il faut les
accepter pendant un temps pour que à la
fin effectivement ça puissent se
mélanger dans notre culture nationale
une culture française républicaine qui
s'impose à tous
il faut prendre les gens là où ils sont
les accompagner et pas hystériser les
débats sinon fabrique de la radicalité
parce que la laïcité à deux vitesses
c'est quand le rassemblement national le
bien mal nommée demande des crèches à
l'hôtel de région à la présidente de
région alors là ça les jeunes parents là
il n'y a pas de problème de laïcité en
revanche que je ris je vais vous
répondre le conseil d'état a statué très
clairement pour les pour les crèches
dans les dents liquide dans les conseils
régionaux conseils généraux ce n'est pas
un signe cultuelle mais un signe
culturel voilà c'est pour ça que dans
certaines baies oui nous mêmes se
sustenter pas comme ceux ci stentys est
simplement de la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état je vous l'apprends
parfait je reviens sur cette histoire de
voile et c'est à vis de la soeur comme
de la soutane du prêtre alors j'aimerais
vous dire ma dire qu'il faut absolument
pas mettre ça sur le même sur le même
plan aristide briand qui était important
de cette loi en 1905 a fait le distinguo
et on a laissé porter aux bonnes soeurs
l'accord n'est t'elle voilée au curé la
soutane en disant c'est l'habit de leurs
fonctions comme le pompier ou comme le
policier donc rien à voir avec le voile
que pour est parti que pourrait porter
un civil
d'autres réactions sur un thème très
différent isabelle par exemple vous dit
il y à une loi faite la respecter et
occupez vous des vrais problèmes
on a aussi plusieurs réactions de ce
type là je vous en lui une autre daniel
qui nous dit nous le démantèle la
sécurité sociale les retraites les
transports publics l'école l'hôpital et
nous on s'engueule pour un morceau de
tissu alain chrétien
ça pourrait presque faire sourire nos
tellement parfois ça peut paraître
évident mais là aussi il faut respecter
les français y ait des français qui
tiennent à ce débat il faut qu'on leur
réponde
il ya une manoeuvre de diversion souvent
les gouvernements sont accusés de faire
parler du voile pour faire passer des
spéciales ou sauvés le feu jeudi soir
les gouvernements je ne pense pas que le
foyer logement de vesoul soit un agent
subversif du gouvernement néo des
pourriels et entretenir les polémiques
sur ces questions-là gouvernement n'a
pas entretenu la polémique de vesoul
non je crois qu'il faut quand même
répondu quoi une fois de voisins est pas
tout à fait d'accord et l'on veut voilà
je pense que le sujet n'est pas là je
crois simplement qu'il ya des français
pour qui pour qui ça compte et c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont peut-être minoritaire
mais ce n'est pas le cas parce que vous
citez le chiffre 70 % il faut pas s'en
occuper
c'est un sujet aussi important sociétal
effectivement ce n'est pas le pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas les préoccupations du
quotidien
il faut qu'on s'en préoccupe mais qu'on
s'en préoccupe de manière sereine en
dehors de toute élection en dehors de
toute propagande politique une dernière
question parce que il est bientôt midi
est ce que les uns les autres vous
connaissez philippe grenier ce que ce
nom vous dit quelque chose on va voir la
photo si on peut nous l'affiché voilà
vous connaissez cet homme c'était le
premier député musulman de france élu du
très conservateur au doux de pontarlier
à la fin du 19e siècle il sait il siéger
dans cette tenue avec l'habit
traditionnel des berbères donc à
l'assemblée nationale il revendiquer
fièrement son sa conversion à l'islam
un élu de la république l'étude la sorte
c'est possible aujourd'hui ou est-ce
qu'on a complètement changé de si vous
voulez nous faire dire que 2020 n'est
pas 1905
c'est clair c'est même avant 1900 que la
société a totalement changé et que il
est évident que tu essaies débat seuil
de tolérance c'est à changer où ça se
passe seulement ça je rappelle que je
rappelle que l'algérie était française
à cette époque là oui voilà donc bon en
tant que là aussi la hausse il a aussi
la laïcité permettait à ce que les
populations autochtones et que et que
l'islam soit représentée il s'est
converti à l'islam c'est fini et chine
1905 c'est depuis après merci à tous les
trois d'être venu sur ce plateau
dimanche en politique continue avec
francis letellier et stanislas guérini
je vous souhaite à tous un très bon
dimanche merci merci
[Musique]